Welcome to Peacock’s Love Island USA
headquarters, where we take the dress code
very seriously.
As you can see, we’re working hard to create
the biggest and best season ever!
Let’s pop over for a quick chat, shall we?
(Clears throat)
Oi! Enough lounging around, you lot.
Get to work!
Date Team, we want more candles!
More red-hot romance, people!
Wardrobe Team, we want less from you - a lot less.
Fire up the shrinking machine!
Challenge Team, let’s go big this season.
Come on! I mean really big!
That’s more like it!
It’s hard work, but someone has to do it!
Hold on to your bikini strings, America!
Your summer of love is back!
I think you’ve had enough there, mate.